morning routines are one of the most
important things that you can create in
your life and the reason is when you
start the day if you get early momentum
going the rest of the day is often going
to follow in that it's an idea called
entropy everything moves towards chaos
and the only way to combat that is to
put energy into the system you are not
going to wake up and randomly have a
good day you're going to have to
structure your day in a way that sets
you up to overcome all of the entropy
all of that chaos all of the thousand
things going to come at you on a daily
basis that are going to knock you off
course and the easiest way to do that is
to have a routine that you follow every
morning so you don't have to think about
it you don't have to reinvent the wheel
you don't have to wonder or think about
what you should be doing it's just right
there it is baked into the routine by
doing that now you can actually
accomplish the most important things
first the thing to do in your morning
routine well is to optimize for what Tim
Ferriss refers to as the lead Domino
what's the thing that if I did this it's
going to make everything else easier
down the road so number one a morning
routine actually starts the night before
you want to to get plenty of sleep why
because that's going to optimize your
cognition the next thing you want to do
is either meditate or work out typically
I will work out first the reason that I
work out is because it optimizes your
cognition so that everything else is
going to get easier it also dramatically
impacts your energy levels talk about
two things that are incredible lead
dominoes if I'm getting sleep and
optimizing my cognition if I'm working
out and optimizing my cognition and I'm
making sure that I have the energy
levels that I need to get things done
now I'm really making sure that
everything that I do after that is
easier need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so would say listen from one of
the best Tom Bilu and my take on his top
10 was a success enjoy
the next thing that I do is meditate why
because it optimizes your cognition you
want to make sure that you're getting
all of your background radiation the
stress the anxiety you want to get that
as close to zero as you can that way you
can think clearly you get into what I
call a calm and creative state so the
areas of your brain that don't often
communicate are able to communicate get
better ideas that way again lead Domino
improving your cognition lowering your
stress levels making sure that you're
centered and that you've got that energy
to move forward then I'm going to go
down my list of important things I make
that list the day before so I know
exactly what I should be doing at any
one time and again it's a lead Domino
strategy what the first thing that I'm
going to do is going to be the thing
that makes everything else on my list
easier I'm going to do everything that I
can do on the most important thing and
by the way they should always be rank
ordered there is no such thing as a tie
there is a number one a number two and
number three and number four so on and
so forth there is not two number ones
there's not two number twos there was a
one two three four five so on and so
forth I do everything that I can do on
number one once that's now where I'm
waiting for something else or you know I
just have to let it bake whatever then
I'm going to move on to number two I'm
going to do everything I can on number
two then I'm going to move on to number
three do you set your day up like that
and you're not checking your phone and
you're not responding to other people
because that's letting them control your
schedule and what are the odds that
somebody other than you knows better
what you should be doing to make your
goals come true than you the answer
should be zero because if somebody else
knows better than you we already have a
problem it means that somebody else is
paying more attention to your own life
than you are that would be problematic
get that morning routine down get that
momentum going do the lead Domino
strategy make sure you're optimizing for
energy and cognition absolutely critical
rule number two wanted bad enough let me
tell you why so many people
procrastinate and experience laziness
number one the most important reason is
people just don't want it badly enough
that is the hard truth that not a lot of
people want to face but the reality is
when you're struggling to get something
done you you have a desire problem there
is a very famous story that I think
perfectly encapsulates what you have to
harness if you really want to accomplish
something difficult think of somebody
drowning being held underwater and
desperately wanting that next breath of
air is the person lets them up and being
dunked back under and held back up and
dunked back under every time that
they're under and they're being held
under think about how badly you want
that next breath of air you would Claw
at their flesh you would tear at their
eyes if you could get a hold of it you
would flip yourself over you would go
deeper into the water to try to push
yourself back up you would do anything
including kill the person that is
holding you underwater to get your next
breath when you want success that badly
you will find a way and when it comes to
being an entrepreneur when it comes to
being successful that's what I always
tell people success is a game of problem
solving but you have to really want to
solve that problem and the only way to
really want to solve that problem is to
build your desire so people have to
understand everything in life is a
process love
is a process you go on dates I don't
believe and love at first sight lust
sure Evolution took care of that for you
but nobody loves at First Sight you
don't know the person well enough you
haven't done the Reps you haven't gotten
to know them you haven't spent the time
with them you haven't developed love
that's why we have dating that's why
first it's dates and maybe not a lot of
commitment it's just getting to know
them and then it's like whoa we're
getting a little bit more serious and
then it's an engagement and then it's
the wedding and then it's the actual
life live together it is a process love
even changes colors and textures as you
go so that in the beginning it's a very
lustful all-consuming drug-like effect
you can actually put somebody
in an fmri machine and scan their brain
and at the beginning in that passionate
love phase there is no difference on an
fmri between somebody who is in love and
thinking of the person that they're in
love and somebody who's on cocaine they
are identical scans
but over time that changes into
something more mature and I would say
more wonderful more sustainable more
incredible now once you understand that
desire in and of itself whether it's for
another person whether it's for a goal
is a process of building desire then you
realize that you can go through that
process you can build up that desire so
when you think about that person having
their head held underwater you can build
that level of intensity in your life to
want something so badly the only way
that you're going to do it the only way
that you're going to escape laziness is
by attaching meaning and purpose to that
thing that you want you have to want it
for a reason as Simon sinek would say
you have to start with why why do I want
this thing and you're tapping into the
evolutionary drivers that you have
embedded in your brain that are going to
compel you to get better
that's a huge part of this whole process
to serve not only yourself but the group
and get to the point where you can
translate your potential into usable
skill set so when you're doing those
three things when you're transferring
your potential making it usable skill
set that's allowing you to actually make
progress it's something that you care
about and serving not only yourself but
other people now you're going to get
into this positive feedback loop that's
light falling in love you're going to be
building that desire because you're
getting good at something progress is a
foundational pillar to human happiness
if you're progressing okay this is
evolution embedding something in your
brain you have a desire to progress
period end of story if you are a human
being you have an embedded deeply
embedded desire
to get better you will never feel a
sense of progress you won't feel good
about yourself you will have a profound
sense of disease if you're not improving
why because that was Nature's Way of
ensuring that you went out and did the
hard things that you would need to do to
feed your family to keep the group
intact to protect yourself from the
devastatingly vicious nature of nature
nature is doing its best to kill you at
all times okay whether it's from
starvation exposure to the elements or
being attacked by a predator we were at
risk constantly throughout our
evolutionary past and all of those
directives that nature had to give us
and implant deep in our brains to make
sure that we went out of the safety of
the cave to go get that next meal to go
find a mate to fight to raise our kids
to make sure that they had kids all of
those things that nature had to embed in
our brain still exist in us today and
they govern our wants desires Behavior
so if we don't take the time to build
add up to Fan those Flames to get us
hyped about this thing that we want to
do for whatever reason if we don't do
that then the laziness kicks in which is
the flip side of the evolutionary coin
so side number one you better get out
you better go do something you better
hunt you better take these risks you
better protect your family you better be
a tough nut that is going to contribute
to the group otherwise you're going to
get ostracized you're going to get left
behind and you're going to die laziness
is about yo this [ __ ] is hard finding
calories is tough you've got to go out
and forage hunt kill Chase
defend yourself against this thing that
you're trying to take down and once you
get those calories it was a lot of work
and oftentimes you had very little to
show for it especially if we're talking
plant matter which from a caloric
standpoint is not very dense and it's
not like it is today where we have Farms
everywhere you had to literally hunt and
forage in dangerous spaces in order to
get those calories so you had to have a
competing desire to chill so you've got
this desire of pushing you forward to
make sure that you do hard things to
make sure that you're progressing
contributing getting better but then
over here you've got this weird ass
completely contradictory desire to chill
because the brain if nothing else there
are two things that just gobble calories
and that is muscle and brain and your
brain by far is the hungriest thing in
your body it's something like two
percent of your body weight and takes up
20 to 25 percent of your caloric intake
just to run your brain so you can
imagine if you've got muscles gobbling
calories even at rest you've got your
brain just mowing through calories to
keep you alive to leverage your
intelligence then you better have a
directive embedded in your brain that
once you've gone out and done the thing
whether it's hunt protect mate whatever
that you then relax so you're always
going to have these two competing
desires it is a very weird part of The
Human Experience so to overcome that
laziness you've got to have a very
compelling reason to go out and Hunt
especially when the grocery store is
right down the street and for very cheap
you can get plentiful calories you can
swipe left or swipe right and decline or
find a potential mate right everything
has gotten so easy you have to have a
compelling reason to go out and do these
hard things but if you don't then you
have this profound sense of disease
because again progress is a foundational
pillar of human happiness so people
procrastinate because nature is telling
them to procrastinate they are lazy
because nature is compelling them to be
lazy and if you don't build the desire
to overcome those things if you don't
build that up walk that process do the
things that you need to do to Fan the
Flames of Desire then you won't you will
chill
you will relax
because that's how nature designed you
so you have to go down the process of
building desire now the process of
building desire is very simple and I
will walk you through it it goes like
this you're going to tell yourself your
why I am doing this for this reason I
want this goal for this reason for me I
want to build this Mega Media Company
because I believe that the only way to
break the relationship between your zip
code and your success is through ideas
that it is a mindset problem a belief
problem a value system problem it is not
a money problem you can actually just by
where you live dramatically increase the
likelihood that somebody will remain
poor generationally okay that's an idea
problem that's a mindset problem it's a
it's a way to think about the problem
problem it's not an IQ problem plenty of
smart people it's an idea problem since
I believe that and I believe that the
best way to get ideas across is through
story I'm building a media company to
help people people like the people that
I have known and loved that did not
succeed because they had the wrong frame
of reference now the idea of frame of
reference is beyond the scope of today's
video because I have known extraordinary
people smarter than me that did not end
up having success that they could have
had if they had that right set of ideas
I have dedicated my life to building
this Media company that gives me a
pretty compelling why they're people
that I know and love that I can think of
when it gets hard and I'm exhausted I'm
tired and I do not want to keep going I
don't think about money I don't think
about adulation I don't think about
recognition all I think about is those
people having a better life or their
kids having a better life and that is
what propels me forward or I flip to the
dark side and I think about the people
that want me to fail again this may be
outside of the scope of what we're
talking about today but I have these
things that I tap into that fan the
Flames of my wanting that make me want
it
badly and when I can capture that sense
of wanting the success the way that a
drowning man wants that next breath of
air then I have the willingness to fight
to keep pushing to do the thing rule
number three be a resilient leader
recognize that in this Dynamic you're a
student and not a teacher and this is
hard man this is really hard for people
but this is the real stuff like this is
where you have to recognize me as a CEO
I've got to recognize when I'm the
student and so I'll put forth an idea if
an expert in that space is like that
doesn't make sense for this reason I'm
like respect this isn't my area of
expertise
but when I know something then I'm going
to go to the mat for it and so you you
want to co-create but within the context
of a meritocracy so never lose sight of
that otherwise you can get paralyzed by
trying to protect everybody's feelings
this is where you come to be hardcore
this is where you come to be resilient
this is where you come to learn where
hey we want your opinion we are
desperate for we don't value ourselves
for being right we want to hear it but
if your idea is bad we're just going to
say it's bad and by the way I want you
to tell me if you think my idea is bad
I'm not above that nobody's above that
we've got a goal we're going for the
goal and anybody that's serving that
goal that idea is going to win every
time
but if all you want is to be heard and
understood then you're going to get
mowed over you have to be more resilient
than that you have to be you have to be
like I want good things for you I want
to see you become a badass in your life
but that means you have to get
really comfortable
with being wrong with taking a chance
and failing with and then people telling
you yeah that didn't make sense and it
didn't make sense for this reason and
then now you've got more information and
you can move forward
so yeah I mean call this a warning
toughen up toughen up toughen the [ __ ]
up buttercup I literally have a t-shirt
that has the initials for that as a
reminder to myself
I don't need people to
hug me all the time pat me on the back
congratulate me cheer me on
I want to be elevated I want people to
want me to win
but when what I'm saying isn't going to
work I want somebody to tell me and I
have a core belief
any idea that can't withstand criticism
isn't a good idea
any idea that can't withstand criticism
by nature is not a good idea
you've got a hunger for criticism to
find out if your idea is good or not
you've got to seek
seek
disconfirming evidence
you've not you shouldn't pursue
Yes Men
you should pursue
as Abraham Lincoln said A Team of Rivals
you don't want people who are trying to
destroy you but you want people who
think differently than you you want
people who see things you don't see and
you want to celebrate those differences
so often
moving forward
is about the friction between
styles of thinking
and you've got to covet that friction
and most people are just trying to
eliminate it most people are just trying
to surround themselves with people to
think like they think
that's dangerous
that will not take you where you want to
go
so I need a cool name for
hardcore
rivalistic
co-creation
because it's not co-creation in any sort
of hey everybody everybody come and
let's do this as a a democracy
this is let's let these ideas battle
and
I don't want deference as the CEO in
fact I ask for people to criticize my
ideas publicly and aggressively now I
don't ask them to do that to other
people because most people are not
prepared for that but I am and I want to
set the tone because I'm obsessed with
my goal I just want my goal to come true
I want to win
and to win you have to get really good
and to get really good
people have got to play against you with
everything they have but as a teammate
this is a team
not a family rule number four earn
respect respect
comes from competence whether it's your
own self respecting yourself doing
something you think is worthy getting
good at something that is valuable
that's how you get somebody else's
respect
you don't get respect by saying you
should treat me this way
and
respect cannot be given it must be
earned and I remember hearing that at
the beginning of my career and thinking
man like I can't just go to somebody and
say hey don't be a like you need to
treat me better and that got me nowhere
it makes you look weak like you said I
mean you literally put in the question
where uh my facade kind of Fades and I
slip back into my normal self and
eventually I completely lose the respect
instead of getting it okay this is a
game of confidence
to be confident you must actually be
good at something I'm sure you've heard
the phrase that confidence comes from
competence okay the same with respect if
you want to get that respect you
actually have to get good at something
if you want to get that respect you
actually have to respect yourself you
want oh God there's a great story so I
interviewed
um
Matthew McConaughey watch the episode
first of all it's fire that dude's
amazing but he in his book green lights
he talks about how he came to Hollywood
and first he was discovered in Texas now
why was he discovered in Texas because
he had Swagger he had that it Factor he
didn't give a sh he didn't want people's
approval he wasn't asking for anything
he wasn't coming to the world with his
hand out this is so critical this was a
turning point in my life don't come to
the world with your hand out don't act
like the world owes you anything the
people that are disrespecting you don't
owe you and you shouldn't want anything
from them you shouldn't be thinking
about them you should be thinking about
becoming a beast that cannot be stopped
because you have a set of skills
that lets you do something other people
can't do
my favorite
one of my favorite quotes all time
certainly my favorite Kobe Bryant quote
booze don't block dunks
if you get so good at something that
people can't stop you they can't stop
you think about being on a basketball
court the other team they are paying
their players millions of dollars to
stop somebody from putting a ball into
the hoop but you can actually get so
good that they cannot stop you from
doing it no matter how hard they try
life
is like that
you actually okay remember skills have
utility
so you can actually get so good at
something your skill set is so Superior
to other people your competitors the
other people in your work environment
whoever
that even though they want to stop you
they can't
because you've just gotten that much
better than they are now back to Matthew
McConaughey goes to Hollywood they
picked him out of obscurity because he
had Swagger he goes there and all of a
sudden he loses that Swagger and before
his
agent I guess would let him go to his
first audition he said no no I can I can
see that you've got your hand out now
that you want something from this town
so we sent him on like a two-month
motorcycle journey across Europe or some
crazy [ __ ] like that and he said when
you're ready and you no longer want
anything from this town and you can just
walk in be you totally unapologetically
then we'll start sending you out on
auditions he did it he comes back he's
got a Swagger he sends him in and
obviously the rest is history
man that that's just hard and I know
that people want an easier path forward
but the reality is you have to get so
good you can dunk on even the people
trying to stop you that's just the truth
and when you do that and you're no
longer wanting other people's respect
you don't care about that all you're
doing is investing in skill set then it
will pay off all sudden people will
respect you and by the way be kind to
people
extend that respect to those that have
earned it of course but don't be cold or
cruel even when people are being that
way to you I just I can't tell you how
much that will pay off in the end also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five lead from the
front on balance people see the rate at
which I improve
they see that I have a goal and I'm a
servant to that goal
and then I build skills based on what
will take me to that goal
and because I win on balance more than I
lose
people still follow
so leadership is not about perfection
it's about progress
have you ever dealt with a bad leader if
so how do you go about it yes
I think we've all seen bad leadership
and it depends on where you're at in the
hierarchy is going to determine how you
can handle it now because I'm the CEO
it's very easy if somebody is displaying
bad leadership you go and explain you're
displaying bad leadership and you
explain what they're doing well what
they're doing poorly what they need to
improve on and how to improve upon it
you just lay it out like I said at
impact Theory there is only one way own
your opinion speak up or get out and
that's not true for anybody more than
it's true for me so I have to tell
people exactly what I think they're
doing right what I think they're doing
wrong and then help them adjust if you
are
reporting to them
then it becomes a very different game
now I would hypothesize that if you have
a toxic leader somebody who is not going
to listen somebody who is abusive
whatever that you have two choices you
can either outperform them and go around
them which I would never be shy or
bashful about
or I would leave the company but
personally I would not just sit there
and suffer in silence so at the end of
the day you want to play a long game so
um you know outperforming I cannot tell
you the number I almost got in a fist
fight once because I got hired at the
same time as another guy and just kept
getting promoted above him until I was a
direct boss and he was very displeased
by that nobody well I won't say nobody
most people can't handle that and in
that
you have to figure out how to
get around somebody that's toxic
on the other hand if they aren't toxic
but they're just
displaying bad leadership an open
conversation with them is the first
place to start give them a chance to
improve based on improved understanding
so coming to them and saying hey
I feel like you led me astray or I feel
like I'm not getting what I need or
whatever the problem is in very simple
clear language don't do it cruelly don't
try to be punitive don't set out to make
them feel bad or stupid just say hey
here's what I'm looking for here's what
I don't feel that I'm getting and I
would love to discuss if there's
something that we can do so that I can
get these things that I need either from
you or from somebody else but oftentimes
people don't realize where they're going
astray and oftentimes people have never
had that kind of direct and open
feedback now it is going to sting that
is going to hurt them and I would
actually encourage you it might be
worthwhile to get one of their peers to
come into that meeting which of course
they're not going to love but you're
going to avoid it he said she said
moment this is where the culture of the
company comes in at impact Theory we
tell people that they need to do that so
if you've got got conflict between two
people you need to bring somebody in
that can sort of mediate that
disagreement so that we can figure out
what's going on we are not an
organization where it's like hey go tell
HR you need to tell that person directly
you need to let them know if you don't
get the response that you want from them
go to somebody else this is not a
company where you suffer in silence this
is not a company where you [ __ ] behind
people's back this is a company where
you speak directly to people now a lot
of people can't handle that
and I get that there are realities to be
faced about feeding your family keeping
a roof over your head all of that
there are also realities to be faced not
everybody's like that there are amazing
people out there that are extraordinary
leaders there are companies with
Incredible culture and you can find them
but you have to look
so in this particular example it starts
with very direct open and honest
communication done in a way that is
protective so that you've got somebody
else there so that there's you know not
going to be some Claim about
insubordination or whatever and
if you really are looking for a solution
and not just a punishment for bad
leadership then you guys can work
together and hopefully get exactly what
you want but open and honest
communication is the path rule number
six focus on making progress I can't
rule out that you may be in a toxic
environment so let's just say if you're
in a toxic environment that's a real
thing you want to get out of that toxic
environment you want to move on to
something else like the just trying to
change a whole organization if they are
toxic is not interesting to me in the
slightest now toxicity comes from
insecurity so if that helps it actually
does help me to know that when people
are
mean-spirited when they like to see
other people fail it's all coming from
their own insecurities I find tremendous
emotional relief in that uh
now I want to talk about being low
in a non-toxic environment
while I don't think anybody races to
have others witness them at their worst
we've all been there we are all deeply
flawed emotional creatures and
showing vulnerability
should never be frowned on for you
forget how people are reacting right so
there's wallowing
and that is an interesting
shouldn't be interesting to you in
yourself or in others there is
wanting sympathy instead of empathy so
sympathy is feel bad for me
you should never want that empathy is
understand where I'm at
being seen is rad
and my wife and I have an agreement
I don't want sympathy from her no matter
how hard my life gets empathy
desperately
and the way that we've always explained
it to each other is if I'm ever knocked
to my knees
I don't want you to get on your knees
with me and cry
I want you to extend a hand
tell me how much you love me
pick me back up brush me off and remind
me of who I can become
that's rad
so I'm not worried if she sees me low
I'm not worried if my team sees me fail
um I think all of us if you're really
going for something extraordinary I
think all of us are going to fail at
least as much as we succeed maybe more
and so fearing the low moments is not
the right way to think about it we
contextualize that failure as a learning
opportunity earn people's respect not
command it earn people's Respect by
getting back up on your feet
not asking people to feel bad for you
focusing on the learning opportunity
show that you have a growth mindset get
your ego out of the way
Focus entirely on getting better
and if you rebound quickly
with energy and enthusiasm
even if some people take the opportunity
to kick you while you're down
in the long run people will gravitate
towards you because they see that you're
real you're not posing they see that you
bounce back that you don't whine wallow
complain you get up you're focused on
Improvement and moving forward and look
the reality is getting great requires
you to fail over and over and over
there's an amazing quote by Winston
Churchill and he says success is the
ability to go from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm
and
you just can't worry about what other
people are thinking when you're down you
have to go cool this is a learning
experience I'm going to get back up and
your response to that shouldn't be
orchestrated to command respect earn
respect to even think about people it
should be you have a goal
and you know to build your skill set to
the point
where you're so good that you can't be
denied that all the booze in the world
can't block your dunk you have to fail
because it really it it really is it
isn't a saying failure is the most
information Rich data stream you will
ever encounter in the failure if you get
your ego out of the way and you're not
crying about it and you're not you know
worried about what other people are
going to think you're just thinking okay
cool I failed and if I can understand
why then I can get better
now you do that day in and day out all
of a sudden you're going to earn respect
as as a consequence of you're just
consistent Improvement
and if I were going to sum up everything
that we've talked about today it's that
it's
not focusing on earning people's respect
or worrying about what they think it's
about
the physics of how the world works and
the physics of how the world works is
pretty straightforward
you have a goal you have an idea of how
to reach that goal right there's an
impediment between where you are and
where you want to be you've got a theory
about how to overcome that impediment
you try it many of the things you try
will fail or they'll be insufficient
you'll assess why it was insufficient
and you'll begin again more
intelligently as Henry Ford said failure
is just the ability to Begin Again more
intelligently and you do that over and
over and over and over and over and it's
what I call the physics of progress it
it's just you can't boil it down any
more simple than that
all right so don't be afraid of your low
moments if you're in a toxic environment
get out focus every day on getting
better and the respect will come as a
result of that rule number seven learn
from Pain there really are only two
macro level motivators that we have in
life and that's Pleasure and Pain and so
what I want people to understand is okay
so if nature only gave you two things to
motivate you Pleasure and Pain why would
you eliminate half of them and so most
people think that life is about avoiding
the pain I'm here to tell you right now
in a very controlled fashion it is about
really experiencing the pain learning
from it so Ray dalio the most successful
hedge fund manager of all time has a
perfect math equation pain plus
reflection equals progress if you don't
feel the pain you never reflect on it so
my thing is I spend eighty percent of my
time focused on the beautiful things in
my life the things I'm grateful for the
beautiful things that I want to bring
into existence all of it 20 of the time
though I'm in the darkness man I'm in
that Tim Grover Relentless I'm going to
make this happen if I have to break
myself and I'm not afraid to lean into
that because I know how powerful it is
now if you really want to put numbers
how powerful this is they did a study
and they wanted to find out what happens
how can we get people to endure more
pain and the punch line is hilarious so
they would take people and they would
submerge their arm in a bucket of ice
and they would just hold it there as
long as you can now at first it's just
cold but after a while it really starts
to hurt and so people would end up
yanking their arms out
they found that people could hold their
arm in the bucket 35 percent longer if
you let them display anger
so put it in they get to that point
where they're about to pull it out and
you tell them yell cuss do whatever you
need to and they'd be able to do it
they're the expression of intensity even
what I'm doing right now I can feel
myself ready right I'm ready to strike
my muscles are tense I've got a
different posture I bring my chin down
there's intensity in my eyes like dude
I'm now feeling that because I'm I'm
embodying it right so it makes me really
feel that and so I actually started to
tell the story earlier I hate the gym
but what I would do to make myself work
out is I would my wife would be on the
opposite side of the gym and I would
stare at her and I would imagine her
being attacked and I would imagine her
being attacked by people bigger than me
and that the only way that I could fight
them off is to get stronger there was
nothing beautiful in it I was not
worried about Aesthetics I was worried
about saving my wife and by stepping
into that dark place and because people
are like what are you doing yeah but
dude that was I needed that motivation
to push past what I want to push past
pain boredom all of it and just to
really get into it and get a result but
I find that people shy away from that
look to me it's an 80 20 split if you're
spending more than 20 percent of your
time there it will be corrosive yes it
will start to erode your sense of self
because you're going to feel badly right
because I would be saying to myself
you're weak come on like you've got to
get stronger if you spend 80 of your
time doing that that sucks yes I don't
want to live like that right but not
being able to dip into both you'll just
never hit the level of extraordinary you
may be fine you may even be good yep but
you're never going to be great rule
number eight boost your productivity
your diet is one of the most important
things you can do to boost your energy
your focus and your productivity what
you should be eating varies wildly and I
will just tell you right now that while
I'm gonna give you a very simple thing
that you can follow and it's going to
take care of 80 of all of your desires
and problems know that there is massive
variability at the individual level and
that you should be testing a lot of
different things to find out what is
right for you so what I'm about to lay
out is the sort of generic strategy you
that I think everybody should try but
getting into the nitty-gritty is going
to require you to do a lot of testing
there is no way around this I wish that
dieting was more simplistic but based on
your lifestyle based on your heredity
based on your microbiome all of this
stuff is going to dramatic to
dramatically vary so be very thoughtful
make sure you run experimentation having
said that what are the things that I
think are Universal number one you want
to be eating Whole Food whenever humanly
possible so you want to eat food that is
recognizable from what it was in nature
so a piece of meat should look like a
piece of meat it shouldn't be highly
processed your vegetables should look
like vegetables I mean you should be
brushing dirt off of them that kind of
recognizable from nature nuts should be
I mean ideally raw I'll be really honest
I do sometimes eat roasted nuts but if
I'm honest that's worse than if you're
just eating them raw so you want things
that are as close to their natural state
assumingly possible the less that they
have been messed with manufactured
altered in any way the better off you're
going to be I will say that heat is
something that I apply to virtually all
of my food there are some really
interesting theories about from an
evolutionary standpoint that cooking is
one of the things that allowed us to
grow the big brain because by cooking it
you not only soften the food make it
easier to chew but you also release some
of the nutrients beyond the scope of
this to get into that but when I say raw
I don't mean that everything needs to be
uncooked I just mean the less processed
the better things that I eat every day I
eat a lot of eggs red meat I eat some
chicken a bit of pork but I'm eating a
fair amount of meat so I get a good
portion of my calories from that again
individual variability if you're doing a
vegan thing word I'm totally about it
test for the individual response that
you get I find that the more plant
forward I go there's like a breaking
point where I start feeling worse could
be me it could be me doing it poorly but
as long as you're doing whole food I
think you're on the money so eating
whole food and making sure that you're
avoiding sugar that is like the big
thing so I don't think you can eat fruit
with impunity I think you have to be
very thoughtful about that if you're
unsure of what fruit is going to impact
you and how I highly recommend getting a
continuous glucose monitor that will
allow you to eat fruit if you want and
see what kind of glycemic response you
have for instance I find that I can make
certain fruit smoothies and if I eat it
slowly enough my glycemic response will
go up to about 120. I prefer to keep it
in the 80s but hey if it goes up to 120
and it's sort of even and it comes back
down I don't consider that too
problematic but if I eat it really
quickly and it spikes up to say 140 150
that to me is problematic and I don't
want to be that high so you can play
with things also what you put in the
Smoothie Etc if you're going to eat
fruit and vegetables make sure that you
separate fruit and vegetables keep those
two things distinct I think you will
find by wearing a continuous glucose
monitor that you're going to have a
dramatically different response to most
fruit than you will to vegetables again
there's a lot of variability here so the
more that you test on yourself the
better but that's really the the sort of
generic response if you're a generic
setup that I think everybody should try
Whole Food whenever humanly possible
avoid sugar keeping your blood glucose
below 100 I highly recommend it for me I
try to keep my glucose in this the
80-ish range that's sort of my default I
also do intermittent fasting I think
that that is very effective getting into
things like autophagy is beyond the
scope of what we're talking about right
now but even that I think it's going to
be huge body composition is greatly
affected by intermittent fasting again
individual variability make sure that
you experiment with this stuff for
yourself I do when you average it out I
think I went about 18 months where I was
tracking every day my average over that
extended period of time was 17 and a
half hours so on the weekends it's it's
shorter but on the weekdays sometimes
it's longer sometimes it's 19 20 21 22
hours that I'll go uh between meals but
again over a very extended period of
time it averages is out to 17 and a half
hours of not eating now the way that I
do that I have my last meal around 1 15.
definitely done chewing by 2 p.m and
then I don't eat again until the next
day at around 9 9 30 somewhere around in
there shorter on the weekends longer
during the week and it it balances out
I'm having everything from green leafy
vegetables like bok choy collard greens
kale broccoli
to carrot jicama I do occasionally have
some sweet potato it'll be a little
thoughtful about that one watch your
glycemic load that definitely spikes me
more than green leafy vegetables but
those are the mix that I use again I'm
eating Whole Foods virtually all of my
calories come from Whole Food during the
week in fact I'd say 95 percent of my
calories come from Whole Foods very rare
that I deviate from that but doing that
allows me to have tremendous focus a lot
of energy get the most out of my
workouts maintain my body composition
key eat my fat low keep my glycemic
spikes low so I'm not getting you know
blood sugar spikes which helps me
maintain my energy through the day and
also just from a longevity standpoint I
think that's a great idea I will say go
look at David Sinclair he's got some
pretty compelling information around the
fact that Meats may not be great for
longevity so while it makes me feel
awesome that's something called mtor so
be thoughtful as you get into the
complex weeds of this stuff nutrition is
a very big complex topic again the only
things that I consider universals are
whole food and reducing sugar universals
close to a universe will be intermittent
fasting though some people can have
differing responses to that so be
thoughtful as you experiment with this
stuff but if you do that like I said 80
plus percent of your problems are going
to go away that's a nice low
inflammation diet and keeping your
inflammation low is incredibly important
rule number nine lead by example that's
an incredible question this is something
that I have lived through so when Quest
was small it was very easy for me to do
what I was saying at the top lead by
example I was there on the production
line I would take the hardest job and we
would literally agree what is the
hardest job this is the hardest job cool
if this is the hardest job I'm going to
be the one that that's going to do it
and I would get in there and I would do
it with all my might and Not only would
I do it but I would uplift other people
I would bring energy and enthusiasm and
I'm an introvert by Nature let me tell
you right now now In fairness I have a
pretty easy time going to extroverted so
my default though is introverted Now by
going on the line by encouraging other
people by taking the hard job all of a
sudden it was very easy for me to get
people to Rally behind me but as we
scaled the company now all of a sudden
there were a ton of people that had
never seen me
working like that so to them I was
almost a mythological figure by that
point I was creating YouTube content so
you know we had 3 000 employees many of
them had never met me
and so to them you know it was like oh
my God that's the guy that runs a
company or the guy that's on YouTube
whatever and it had a really problematic
effect on the way that they approached
me and so what I began to realize is you
have to have a culture you have to show
people up close what gets results
intoxicate them with certainty okay
that's a huge part if you really want to
take your leadership game to the next
level you want to make sure you know
exactly what needs to be done so within
the world of influence you're trying to
have you know where you're trying to go
so you have a goal very clear goal you
can articulate that goal this is where
we're going and then you never
and I mean never
let somebody outwork you and when you
have certainty on where you're going you
tell other people what that is we're
going to go after this most people live
their entire lives doubting themselves
doubting the path that they're going on
and even when you know and some element
of what I'm saying isn't going to work
out but you believe to the core of your
being I'll adjust I'll figure it out now
you can intoxicate people with certainty
and just go like a bat out of hell
towards that thing working in a way that
nobody else is going to match and if
when you do that you elevate those
around you rather than say hey why are
you losers not working as hard as me you
say hey we're a team I want to lift you
up I want to help you I want to help you
get there okay so now you've established
that with those around you in that near
group you make that the culture this is
how we move here this is what we're
about so
you're as good as what you can write
down so you write down what that culture
is you let people know what it means to
be a part of this team
then when they get in you're encouraging
them you're elevating them
you start with the people closest to you
because you're you've been able to write
the culture down you know which way they
have to act you hold them accountable
you ask them to hold you accountable
right you're not trying to be above this
you're trying to be in it trying to show
people what it means so now you've got
your core group then they're going to
have their Core group and then that Core
group is going to have their Core group
and now that influence goes down so you
definitely have to set the example but
when you scale you have got
you have got
to get people to understand what the
culture is
get them to lead by example get them to
intoxicate people with certainty get
them to
show people what it means to have a goal
and to go after it and to live up to the
standards of that culture and now when
you elevate people and you're lifting
them up and you're not trying to beat
them down
then you get something really really
incredible then people will follow you
because it's a game of elevation it's a
game of skill acquisition it's a game of
goal accomplishment it's not [ __ ]
you're not wasting people's time you're
really making progress and progress is
one of the most foundational pillars of
human happiness and Rule Number 10 the
law last one before some very special
bonus Clips is improve your skill set in
the beginning of my business career
first of all I knew nothing so people
were right to question me why I was
there what the value I was offering and
I remember in the beginning this was
back at a technology company uh when I
first started I was hired as a
copywriter with by the guys who would
later become my partners but at the time
I was just an employee and people were
asking who's the kid in the server room
I was the youngest person in the company
nobody took me seriously I was working
in an office where everybody had
floor-to-ceiling windows with a view of
the Pacific Ocean it was absolutely
stunning except for me and I was put in
the server room which is the sort of
business equivalent of Harry Potter
living under the stairs I didn't have
any windows I remember being so
embarrassed bringing my wife to the
office because there were no windows I
didn't even have like a proper desk I
just sat in a room full of the servers
that were running the technology that we
were building and I thought okay nobody
takes me seriously I remember one guy we
ended up letting him go and he was so
pissed that I was in the room uh during
his termination and so
there was a lot of sort of pressure
against me people thought that um
rightly so by the way in the beginning
that I didn't know what I was doing and
it took so much time and energy to grow
and get to the point where I was adding
enough value that I couldn't be denied
and that took me years
but I put in that work I picked the
things that I wanted to get good at I
put an inhuman amount of effort I'm
talking working to the point where my
wife finally had to pull me aside and
say you're now damaging the marriage you
were working so much
so I recognized that what this was was a
game of skill set and if a normal person
was going to be convinced of my skills
um you know say at Point C these guys
weren't going to be impressed by my
skills until Point Q fine I'm aiming for
Point Z and I'm going to go that hard
I'm not going to ask permission I'm
going to really try to add value I'm not
going to see this as antagonistic I'm
not going to take anything on I'm not
going to see like you know them and I'm
just trying to beat and crush them what
I wanted to do was get so good that I
could deliver so much results tangible
results for the company that people
would want me on their team and that
more and more people would covet to have
me help them that I would reach out to
people and try to add value to them even
if it wasn't my job and just see what
are the things that I can do to help and
by adopting that attitude knowing that
as I was helping people I was getting
better I was becoming more valuable I
was taking things on myself I was trying
to look beyond my job description I was
just trying to get so freakishly good
that one I could go anywhere if I wanted
to I didn't have to stay in that company
two if I'm honest at that point what I
was trying to do was earn equity in the
company so for five years I didn't ask
for a raise I just put my head down and
all I wanted to do was become a partner
and I was just learning and learning and
learning and learning and if somebody
made fun of me dunked on me
um yelled at me whatever I just
self-soothed that was the big thing was
I realized one of my superpowers was I
could self-soothe faster than anybody
else I could focus on skill acquisition
and I tied my identity entirely my
entire ego all of my pride was around
getting better
and by focusing relentlessly on skills
not worrying about other people in fact
trying to help them take on way more
than my job description put time in
nights weekends to learn a skill set
that I knew would be valuable to the
company and I wasn't even asking for
anything in exchange I just wanted to
prove
that I could get so good that they were
better off offering me a piece of the
company than losing me to somebody else
and that like that's that thing it's
become so frowned on in this culture to
work more than you're being compensated
for and I'm telling you right now if you
really want an extraordinary life
trying to optimize for your dollars in
the short term is a losing proposition
you want to over deliver consistently at
a freakish level and then when you've
done that
then you can make real demands demands
that will change your net worth forever
that's commanding respect
first and foremost we are going to have
to figure out what exactly has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
Define that because let me be very clear
passion is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn in words look inside
yourself and find this glowing Ember of
passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if Steve Jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iPhone what ends up happening is you
decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it and then over time that
investment turns that thing into a deep
and abiding passion as you get better
and you get feedback from the world that
they value this thing that you're
getting better at but it isn't just
lying dormant within you and this is
like the number one confusion that I
encounter with people is they think that
either they're broken and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if I do enough introspection
I'm gonna find something sitting inside
of me and finally my life will be
amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these Sparks of
Interest
and from that spark of Interest
through pursuing it as
a process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion when you're
able to use that skill set that you
gained in the pursuit of Mastery to
serve not only yourself but other people
okay so doing that now you're in this
passion Loop of you worked really hard
you gained a set of skills allows you to
serve other people they give you
feedback oh my God thank you this is so
amazing I'm grateful for what you've
done build created given me whatever the
case may be and that feels good which
makes you want to go get better and
that's the passion Loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to really be energized by
the things you're doing
but it doesn't start by looking Inward
and finding something it starts by
realizing that you have to Fan those
flames of that spark of interest to turn
it into the Raging Inferno that you want
to feel of that passion but that comes
from that Loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have or had a passion
but this job has somehow beaten it out
of you that's a very different story and
so if that's what's going on we need to
figure out what is it in the structure
of that that is robbing you of that
what's going on exactly that's making
this overwhelming or stressful or not
fun is it politics in the office is it
just the work environment is too fast
paced is it that you're not being honest
with yourself about you know going back
to this idea 50 of you is hardwired 50
of you is malleable if the hardwired
part is out of step with the life that
you're trying to lead there can be a lot
of frustration there so having the
self-awareness to understand did you put
yourself in the wrong position are you
trying to be Steve Jobs when you should
be Steve Wozniak that's a really
imperative thing to look at now I find
that a lot of times uh companies have
their own issues whenever you get a
large group of people together there are
going to be weird things that have to be
navigated but at the end of the day
while you you can't control everything
that everybody does you can always
control how you react and so you can
reorient yourself within a company to
figure out one if there's a
a path back to finding that Joy but that
comes from breaking down what exactly
happened that made you stop feeling the
joy and two are you able to perform at a
high enough level that you're able to
create the space for you to get back on
track because if you're going to go in
and try to move things around and make
some changes within the company or
within your role or within how things
work you're gonna need to be performing
at a very high level to have the
credibility to make that ask and this is
where it gets difficult nobody wants to
hear this I get it everybody wants to
point fingers and say this is just a
toxic company but in reality if it's
that bad leave do not waste time start
find another job first I'm not just
saying quit find another job but get out
of there don't act like you're actually
in prison you are not actually in prison
and yes I understand that you have
obligations and you may be a single
parent with kids and huge responsibility
I completely understand and I have the
most empathy for that in the world but I
want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable that's where we have to start
and so building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay now we need that skill set to
perform at a very high level to create
the credibility to make the ask and go
to your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say I'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
God you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that I would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job and instead
of doing the work themselves solving the
internal problem of how we ended up here
whether it's lack of skill set not
setting boundaries whatever the case may
be but keeping that ownership keeping
that responsibility recognizing that if
you make different choices you get
different outcomes so that you can go
ahead and change things there now again
if you want to leave leave by all means
take your skill set and go elsewhere but
make sure that you're not doing what I
was doing in my early 20s when I was
about to move to New York because I was
unhappy in LA and I thought the LA was a
problem in reality it was my mindset
once I changed my mindset suddenly I was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and I thought ah like
something's got to change and so I just
wanted to go as far away as I could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem I
would have gotten to New York only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
I had to address my mindset and once I
did that then everything changed
so be very careful be very thoughtful
about
how you approach unwinding this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently your
letting your psychological immune system
take over
make it other people's problems and then
you're not able to change
and once you realize that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem
you're never going to get rid of the
fear of following your passion let's
start with that
as you said there is no such thing as
arriving in life and this is one of the
main ideas that I want people to really
grapple with as you think about how to
live your life well is that there is no
success big enough that you can stand in
that success and that it will last
forever really this is a game of
neurochemistry this is how you feel this
is what stresses you out this is what do
you love this is an Ever Changing roller
coaster of emotions and so understanding
that you could fail at a job that you
hate I think this was Jim Carrey's uh
advice to his father that you could fail
at a job that you hate so you might as
well at least try the one that you're
going to love now that doesn't mean that
we just uh throw caution to the wind and
we're going to get more into that with
some of the subsequent questions but
recognizing that
you will never
reach a destination the only destination
in life is death and that is not a
worthy aim you shouldn't be thinking
about that or focusing on that or
thinking uh in terms of you know I just
need to get to 95 or 150 or whatever age
you're aiming at this really is a
question about how you want to feel
every day and once you understand that
that there are things that make you feel
alive those things you're passionate
about those things that give you more
energy than they take and then there are
things that take more energy than they
give and so you want to be very careful
to structure your life in a way that
you're doing something that gives you
more energy than it takes okay so we
know that we're never going to arrive
because we know that we're never going
to arrive we understand that this is
really just a game of emotional
management because we know that this is
a game of emotional management then what
we're asking is what is this thing that
gives us passion is it giving us the
neurochemistry that we want or is the
thing that we're passionate about so
high risk that even though it would be
fun in the abstract once I really commit
to that and make it my job it stops
having that same sense of giving me
energy and that's the tension this is
where people end up not being able to
make a decision because they have not
yet figured out how to optimize their
life in such a way that they can pursue
that thing that they're passionate about
without
that sense of joy and excitement and
that incredible thrill of getting better
at something that you love doing and
that even when it's hard it's giving you
that energy
because people can get lost in that they
get in there they think this is going to
be amazing that passion turns into a job
and then they lose the enthusiasm or
there's so much stress and pressure
around having to be successful at that
passion because you no longer have the
safety net of a job or whatever the case
may be
um they don't recognize that just
pursuing something that's your passion
on paper isn't necessarily going to
solve that problem that the problem
fundamentally is that life is an
ever-changing roller coaster of emotion
and the name of the game is to
manage those emotions well okay so how
do we set it up if we have a passion and
we want to follow that how do we do it
well
so we know that we're never going to get
rid of the fear until we have
predictability and
um
stability in terms of the financial
things that we need and I would say we
want to take care of that we want to
make sure that we have as much Safety
and Security on the financial side as we
can to give us the room to pursue the
things we're passionate about now the
fastest way to do that is to cut your
expenses to the quick if you don't have
an expensive lifestyle this becomes a
whole lot easier and one of the mistakes
that people make is they're living a
lifestyle that's beyond their means and
so they have to keep making this massive
monthly nut and so it becomes very
stressful to pursue that thing that they
love okay so we're either going to
recognize that we have to reduce our
expenses so that we don't have to worry
so much about money or if we already
have a job that pays well we have to
pursue our passion in nights and
weekends fashion such that we can build
that Financial stability so that we can
then progress okay so getting that
stability there I think is really
important the people that have the
strongest home life take the biggest
risks and oftentimes pursuing that
passion is going to be a risk so instead
of trying to eliminate the fear we're
going to structure our life in such a
way that the things that trigger the
fear aren't as high risk okay that's a
big part of this then we want to make
sure that we're structuring our passion
in such a way that it doesn't end up
robbing us of the joy so we want to
experiment with what our passion looks
like as a financial Endeavor and I think
that's a very important experiment to
run again nights and weekends without
making any major life choices is going
to be very important now if we're in a
situation where the odds are stacked
against you this is where the first two
things we just walk through become
incredibly important you want to make
sure that you've got your finances taken
care of so that if this fails that it
doesn't drag you down that will make it
not fun and again there's no
accomplishment so great that you can
stand in that forever so even if you
were to be successful you still have to
deal with the emotional management
so do not put yourself in this hyper
stressful situation where it's you're
always living for the future because the
Success is Not Guaranteed but the
struggle is so the key is to struggle
well that's the answer get after it to
make progress and to fail forward to
really figure out when you make this
catastrophic error
you have to conceptualize it in the
right way so when you're trying
something recognize that as a hypothesis
so number one is to recognize I have a
goal my goal is over there I'm here
there's a gap between my goal and I I
need to know what that Gap is I need to
understand it I need to know what the
impediment is I need to recognize why if
I just keep doing the thing that I'm
doing now why am I not going to get
where I'm going okay so first you have
to identify that now once you identify
that then it becomes a question of what
is your best guess which we will call
which is called a hypothesis so you make
that hypothesis which again is just your
best guess as to what you would need to
do it's very important this isn't
thinking we're not going to live in the
abstract that when we finish this it's
going to tell us to do something so what
would I need to do
in order to overcome the obstacle that
stands between me and my goal if your
major goal is like way down the road
you're going to have to break it down
into smaller goals and so this goal with
my next 15 minutes is how I tell people
to think of it when you understand your
goal clearly enough and you understand
the impediments clearly enough you know
exactly what you should be doing with
the next 15 minutes okay that's the
level of clarity that you need so okay
cool
I've identified this what the thing is
that I believe I need to do it's a guess
don't wait for lightning to strike don't
wait for anything to be self-evident
you have a best guess as to what you
should do with the next 50 minutes and
then your 15-minute stack up to your
best guess you know over uh a week or a
month or a quarter you know whatever
however big that project is
then you're going to do that thing
so I have a hypothesis on what would be
the most efficient way most effective
way for me to overcome this obstacle and
then I'm going to do that thing and that
thing is either going to work or it's
not and if it works amazing did it work
as well as it could have if not and I
have to do this it's something I have to
do again then refine and do it again if
it did then what's my next obstacle and
I'm going to do that one now eventually
you're going to do something and it
doesn't work it either you stood still
or you made so little progress as to be
um Unworthy of Celebration or maybe you
even move backwards maybe this is that
moment where you totally embarrass
yourself maybe this is something that
happened out in public and now you look
like a total ass and in that moment you
need to go okay
why did this not work okay so this is
where we analyze the data now the key to
analyzing the data is before you run
this experiment you need to say what
success looks like so all right if I
think here's my best guess as to what I
need to do to overcome this problem
and here is what success will look like
so
um let me give you an example
we had a hypothesis I still can't
believe that this is true but it is we
had a hypothesis here on our YouTube
channel that if we put
guests uh if we took a photo of them or
pulled a screenshot from the episode
where they're doing something with their
hands that the click rate will go up and
that the click rate will positively
impact our monetized views okay so
that's our hypothesis we test it
I still can't believe this is true but
it works and it doesn't just work most
of the time it works almost all of the
time now nothing is you never have one
blanket statement where it truly works
for everything but I'm talking north of
95 so hey we had this hypothesis it
worked we did it now the number of times
where we had a hypothesis hey uh
should put make the text white with a
um drop shadow we tried it and that
didn't work and it's like wow I can't
believe that didn't work it looks so
much better than black text
but it keeps losing over and over and
over so in that moment it's like okay
well I really thought this was going to
work but it didn't work and you try
something else now when it's something
where there's emotion involved that gets
harder for people to get clear on what
the data is and that's why you have to
have a uh a very clear understanding of
what success looks like in fact right
now we're all going to make a promise to
ourselves you can do it silently we
don't have to have everybody shouting it
out
but you're gonna make a promise to
yourself right now because if if you
follow through with what we're about to
say everything will be different if you
fail to do this you'll come back a year
from now and you're going to write the
same [ __ ] on the wall I promise because
this is the part that you have to break
out of make yourself a promise right now
that you will
disengage your sense of self your sense
of self-worth
from Achievement
and you're gonna marry that
to Pursuit
Once You Are Holy focused on sincere
Pursuit everything changes when you're
focused on outcome when you're saying to
yourself I want to get rich I want to
win the Academy Award ah those are my
dreams it's an end state right it
doesn't work like here's one of those
things things become trite because
they're so true so please for the love
of God don't make people repeat the most
obvious ever like money can't buy
happiness
okay money can't buy happiness it can
buy a lot of cool
it bought me a really nice house
in fact baby show the photo yeah
we actually own part of that jet company
I'm not joking how crazy is that we know
the CEO there was one time where I was
trying to get on the flight and they
were giving me I can't remember why and
I called the CEO up and I was like yo
you need to talk to your gate agent
like that's money
it's bananas
money is better than you think it is
more powerful than you think but it is
not at all what you've been told money
solves money problems and that's awesome
and there's a lot of cool stuff that you
can do with money there's no joke so we
run impact Theory out of our house our
house is like 10 000 square feet
swimming pool balconies all that crazy
[ __ ] one of our rooms is actually called
like actually when we bought the house
they called it this it's called the
great room
and that thing is big
I'm not joking we once played um Nerf
with Nerf guns we did like a whole hide
and seek capture the flag thing in the
house it was crazy
so money does really extraordinary
things people will chase money forever
because money actually has utility so I
am not the guy that's saying oh money
doesn't matter or money's not a thing or
money's not worth a Pursuit what I am
saying though money really can't buy
happiness the very thing you're pursuing
in your life is very simple it is
fulfillment that's it now I sum up
fulfillment very simply how do you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
do you feel good do you feel like you're
making the most of your life are you
tapping into what the Greeks call Techni
are you working your ass off and that's
a key component is it hard are you
working your ass off
sad but true are you working your ass
off for a set of skills
this is oh you this is the angry face
this this is this is about tapping into
rage we talked about that Elizabeth not
at rage yet we'll get there
but there we go
so you really have to
work hard
for a set of skills
that matter to you now the skills have
to matter that's a key part of the
equation
once the skills matter to you and they
allow you to serve not only yourself but
other people and then you actually go
and serve those people it becomes this
really potent cocktail of neurochemistry
but I want to make sure that everybody
understands the game that you're playing
is a game of neurochemistry right in the
last year at least two billionaires
committed suicide
so I mean like it's heartbreaking When
anybody commits suicide but when
billionaires start committing suicide
like if the answer is not just
self-evident beyond all imagining that
money is not going to solve the problems
that exist between your ears like
there's there's nothing more anyone can
tell you a fool never learns
a smart man learns from his mistakes a
wise man learns from the mistakes of
others on this one I'm begging you be
wise I'm not telling you not to chase
money I'm just saying it's not going to
feed you emotionally the way you think
it is so you've got to completely
Divorce Yourself from this notion of
outcome and become completely obsessed
with the idea of sincere Pursuit
now why sincere Pursuit
the reason to tie your sense of self
your self-esteem your pride your ego
your identity all of that the reason to
tie that to sincere Pursuit is it's the
only part you can control
I cannot promise you that you'll ever be
successful
you cannot promise you that you will be
successful
but you can
promise and know if you actually did it
to show up every day and really pursue
it
you control your mindset
you control how you feel about yourself
nobody can actually get you to feel some
kind of way about yourself
you allow that [ __ ] in right that's like
the cheesiest self-help you're ever
gonna hear but it got cheesy because
it's so true so people repeated it a lot
and if you lose sight of that if you
lose sight of what you allow yourself to
think is going to control you at a
neurochemical level
and at the neurochemical level that's
going to influence then again how you
feel and how you think and then you get
into this death spiral where you're
thinking negative you believe in the
negative which makes you feel badly
about yourself and then you get stuck in
that and you can't get out and you see a
lot of that on the hopes and fears
people afraid they're never going to be
able to break free people in this room
that took the time to write it down that
they were never going to get out of that
negative Loop
and that negative Loop is really real
but here's the thing the negative Loop
is based in biology
and once you begin to understand what
the biology is exactly then you can
begin to take control of your life and
step one in the biological train is to
break the tie that you have between
outcome
and worth
once you begin to break that down then
you can step to naked and raw and say
all right this is just practice
and once you're in that mode of
practicing you're in skill acquisition
mode
and the name of the game is skill
acquisition like it really is sort of
that dull and boring it's just about
getting so good at something that you
can't be denied
and that's one of those things like I'm
gonna say that phrase so much that I
worry that's going to become trite but
that is one of the most
awe-inspiring Notions on the planet
the thought that you could become so
good at something
that you leave people in awe
and when you can leave people in awe you
can do just about anything you want with
your life what steps can I take to bring
my focus to the one thing I'm working on
while blocking out all else
all right so the real key is you've got
to learn to compartmentalize so what I
do to begin my compartmentalization is I
create a list of all the important
things that I should be working on I put
that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what I should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's I'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so I've got a lot
of things many things competing for my
attention but I know what my important
things are I'm working on the number one
thing right now let's say and so up this
is my entire world and if I find myself
wandering I bring myself back now part
of the reason that I can invest so
heavily in that is because I have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so since behaviors follow
beliefs you want to make sure that you
put that belief in place which is true
by the way that you can do everything
that you want to do just not all of it
at once so everything has to be done
sequentially you can't do everything at
the same time and this is why you have
to prioritize things out so if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what I have which is
high switching costs when I get in a
flow man I can go and go and go but if I
try to bounce back and forth between
things then I pay this high price and
inefficiency between the switching costs
of moving from switching from that task
to this task so I focus I stay on one
thing I have them in order I know what
I'm working on I remind myself that I
only have one job in that moment that is
to work on that thing I know that that's
the most efficient way to work and I
know that I'm good at prioritizing
things so it becomes very easy boom boom
boom and then you just hold yourself
accountable to actually doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project if something is
really high value really important the
most important thing you could be
dealing with then you're going to do
everything you can do to move that ball
forward now inevitably no matter what it
is there will be times where you will
get to the point where you need a break
or there's nothing more that you can do
whatever
and so you're going to do everything
that you can do to push that ball
forward and then once you need to move
on for whatever reason then or you're
waiting for something then you go and
focus on the smaller things but don't be
afraid to say this is my number one
priority and so other things are going
to get less attention so one thing I
always tell people at impact theory is
doing less is always an option what's
not an option is hating your life okay
so we're not going to do things that
allow us to hate our life so if I know
hey I've got a health issue I have to go
really ham but I also have all this
knick-knacky [ __ ] that I have to
deal with
I'm going to take care of my health
first and foremost I'm going to cut out
things that don't have
you know anything to do with that
because they are less important to me
and we went through this with Lisa and
that meant that she was doing less at
work
um you know if you have to take paid
time off or whatever do it if you have
to take unpaid time off do it if you
have to scale your lifestyle back to
make sure that you can take unpaid time
off do it there are a thousand ways but
when something is truly the most
important thing then you need to address
it as such now what I find is everybody
tries to have these dueling competing
number ones they think that they're
supposed to be doing all of these things
at the same time
I'm just here to tell you that's not how
it works so you have to put things in
rank order there is no such thing as a
dual number one priority okay there is
number one there is number two three
four five six so on and so forth okay so
line them up do them in that order and
you have to be relentless about it and
you have to accept that not everything
is going to get done as well as you want
to get it done but it should get done in
priority order
I find people have a really hard time
with that that one to me is a bit weird
if your priorities are listed in order
of the things that are important to you
why would you do them in any other way
unless you're lying to yourself about
what's actually important to you so if
what's really important to you is what
your parents think about you well then
you might start making stupid decisions
because you're not being honest that
what you really want is to please your
parents now once you start being honest
about what your priorities are like for
instance let's say you have a health
issue and you have kids and the reality
is that your kids are your number one
priority and your health is number two
now what do you do
you've got a choice you either have to
de-prioritize your children which is
going to be hard for some people or your
spouse or your job or whatever but be
honest and if you're not prepared to
de-prioritize your kids then you have to
own that and accept the consequences
namely depending on what your health
issue is you may die younger than you
otherwise would because you're not
addressing it
this is where we got to be honest we
have to say what's really going on we've
got to say what our priorities really
are and when we stop bullshitting
ourselves about what our priorities are
then we can execute in priority order
and then everything in life gets clear
and simple doesn't get easy
but it gets clear and it gets simple
do it to it as my mom would say one
perfectionism isn't going to be the
thing that serves you what you want to
do is focus on what goal are you trying
to attain and then what's it going to
take to get to that goal 99 times out of
100
when you're doing something let's say at
80 perfect you get the result you get
the vast majority of the accolades or
the success metrics all of it can be got
without having to go all the way to that
last 20 and that last 20 is when you can
drive yourself absolutely insane so you
want to be really thoughtful about what
standard you're holding yourself to
because if all you're thinking is man
it's all the way or it is nothing then
what you have to admit is your goal is
perfection your goal isn't the thing
you're trying to accomplish right the
goal is to be a better parent or a
better spouse or better your job the
goal as you are behaving
is perfection now if when you say yes my
goal is perfection it's not the thing
that I'm doing it's it is being perfect
so if I'm going to brush my teeth I am
going to brush my teeth perfectly
wonderful then at least you're being
honest and just know that by trying to
be that perfect you're going to far
narrow the scope of things that you can
do in a way that you wouldn't have to at
least not as much if you were say I'm
just after this goal by this date and I
may have to win ugly but I'm going to
get there
that attitude gives you a lot more
freedom you can get in there you can
throw punches you can get muddy but as
long as you get to the end and you get
across the line and you get that Victory
and that was what it was about then
things get a lot more interesting a
you're not going to be paralyzed by
perfectionism B you're valuing yourself
for achieving that thing going through
it fighting through the mud crawling
making mistakes all of that but you got
there in the end and then the big thing
in all of this is priority order and
this is where people really struggle you
have to be willing to put things in
order now this is where people struggle
because they feel a tremendous sense of
guilt that they have to do all of those
things as their number one priority
let me break that for you you cannot
have multiple number one priorities you
can't do it so I'll give you my life how
I go
my marriage is my number one priority my
business is number two and my family 's
number three
that's reality now I'm sure as my family
members is not lovely to think that
you're in third place but my thing is
I'm trying to spend when I spend time
with them I'm spending quality time I am
focused on them I am a hundred percent
there I'm trying to be perfect but I'm
completely engaged and by being
completely engaged they don't feel like
they're in position three because I've
allocated that time to be with them and
I'm not trying to work at the same time
that I'm with them when I'm with them
I'm with them and that's that but in
terms of making sure that things are
done in order
they're in that order so if cleaning
house is really important to you but
it's your fourth priority
then it's going to suffer and then the
question becomes why would you beat
yourself up for doing things in the
right order so you know that there is a
finite amount of time you know that if
these are the five things you want to
accomplish you only have 100 of time
you're going to allocate a certain
percentage of your time to each of those
then what you're saying is this will get
the results that the percentage of time
that I've allocated to it allows it to
get and just being really comfortable so
I don't beat myself up over that because
I know it's physics I am up against
physics I cannot slow time down so the
reality is that I'm only going to be
able to get so much done now of course I
can work to be to be coefficient and all
of that stuff and I do but at the end of
the day I realize that either holding
myself to this ridiculously high
expectation of perfectionism actually
reduces the number of things that I can
get done because that final 20 ends up
taking more time and energy than the 80
that got the result anyway
so looping around that
instead of saying cool I'm going to get
there I might have to win ugly but I'm
going to get there and then putting
things in order so that I know yep the
thing at the bottom belongs at the
bottom for a reason and it is not going
to get the time and attention that the
other things are going to get
because that's how ordering things works
so you have to be Fearless when it comes
to putting things in order but oddly
enough really really a lot of people get
tripped up with that don't let that be
[Music]
own it
own what matters to you in order write
it down and stick to it
if you do that
you don't need every little thing to be
perfect you can make some crazy progress
in the things that matter most other
things will fall by the wayside it is
what it is how do you know when it's
time to refuel and choose self-care
instead of continuing to grind
physiological self-awareness is critical
I hear a lot of talk about people
developing psychological self-awareness
so understanding
um
what you're good at what you want to do
all of those things incredibly useful
but understanding how to read your body
may be even more important than that so
Lisa Feldman Barrett's book how emotions
are made detail the way that emotions
are far more of a bottom-up phenomenon
meaning they come from your body it
isn't you thinking about something and
then creating the emotion down that does
happen and of course you can spiral
yourself out of control simply by
thinking but usually what begins this
thinking process is a sense of unease
right anxiety is a bodily feeling
oftentimes disconnected from what you're
thinking so figuring out why do I have
the sense being able to process it
consciously we can pull it up into our
conscious mind and think through it with
words and logic but oftentimes it's
starting with that like oh man I don't
feel good about this and I don't know
why so this is the fascinating thing
about drugs is drugs can either
eliminate or change the bodily sensation
which then changes the story story that
you're telling yourself about the
sensation now this isn't an
advertisement for drugs it's to get you
to understand that it can be risky to
sever the sense of body from what you're
telling yourself about it so you want
your body to give you this description
of what is going on but then as you take
conscious control of that to develop
that self-awareness around
physiologically what's happening you
need to understand why you're feeling
the way that you feel and so developing
that to get a sense of whether
this is a time to keep pushing through
or whether this is like one of those
moments where you actually really do
need to step back it's the difference
between sore muscles from you know a
nice hard workout and a torn muscle or
damage joint from an injury and the same
thing is true when you're thinking about
how hard to work how hard to push
yourself you need to figure out this
fatigue that I'm feeling this unease
this anxiety this stress is this a
natural part of pushing through the
difficulties of this project or is
something else going on this is now
really starting to cave in on me and
what I need to do now is take a step
back
meditate
Journal
hug my significant other pet my dog
cuddle my kids whatever the case may be
go for a run
but doing something that
slows you down
lets you take a deep breath
and the only way to figure that out
is to be able to interpret
the feelings that your body's giving you
into conscious thought okay and getting
good at that Loop is very very important
and it takes practice it takes
understanding what the body is
communicating why it's communicating it
what impacts it like what you eat and
drink has a huge impact on what your gut
is telling you and then your brain tries
to make sense of it and it doesn't
always go oh I'm feeling anxious because
in my case I was drinking a zero calorie
monster which much to my dismay because
I absolutely love them
make me feel anxious and so
getting an understanding of that
seeing that pattern was actually quite
transformational because I stopped
drinking them and my anxiety levels
plummeted by like 70 it's pretty crazy
didn't take me to zero but it made it a
phenomenon that was easily manageable
through meditation
so this is where you have to develop
that awareness that pattern recognition
and be able to say oh I feel this way
because of XYZ thing happening at work
or with my spouse or with food that I'm
consuming so be very thoughtful about
that and that will then help you
determine whether it's we need self-care
we just need to push through you're
setting your expectations too high
you're triggering this sense of
inadequacy in yourself so I will tell
you that kicking yourself in the ass is
super powerful
but my rule is I never do anything that
diminishes my sense of self why because
it actually makes you less effective and
effectiveness at moving towards my goal
is the barometer by which I judge
whether something was a success or not
and if I have made a decision and it
moves me away from my goals because it's
making me feel badly about myself
because I've set a standard that's too
high I'm nitpicking myself to death now
I'm getting worse that's moving me away
from my goal and so I'm not going to do
that I don't allow that in my life I
don't allow it in my life I do not allow
myself to do things that diminish my
sense of self and move me backwards so
when I feel it happening I'm like hey
even if it's true even if I Am The
Biggest Loser That Ever Walked this
Earth reinforcing that myself will make
me capable of less therefore I don't do
it I have a bright line in my life that
says I only do and believe
that which moves me towards my goals so
we're just going to recognize as we set
these expectations that it doesn't make
sense to do anything that diminishes
ourselves so we're not going to set
expectations that are so high that we
know that we are bound to fail or to set
high expectations I love that reach for
the farthest star in the world
but don't value yourself for whether or
not you achieve it value yourself for
the sincere Pursuit meaning you really
showed up you really tried to get to
that far star to achieve some insane
goal it was not rhetoric you really
showed up you got in there you bled for
this thing but the whole time you're
valuing yourself you're cheering
yourself on because you're really trying
you're the man in the arena
covered in Blood Sweat and dirt
you might be getting your ass handed to
you
but you're trying and if you're trying
then you should be rewarding yourself
and if you're rewarding yourself then
you should feel better about it which
makes you more likely to get back in the
ring and fight and if that is the thing
that leads you towards your goals which
of course it is then we know that we are
going to do and believe in that thing
because now we're in the arena we're
fighting our behaviors line up with our
desire to achieve that goal so don't
worry about whether or not you actually
ever get there because let me tell you
success
cannot be guaranteed
struggle can you will struggle I cannot
guarantee that you will be successful
juice is never going to be the success
it's never going to be the accolades
just as there is no Feast so Grand that
you will never be hungry again
there is no accomplishment so profound
that it won't be fleeting
no matter how big no matter how much
money you make
it will never be quote unquote enough
because you're playing a game of
neurochemistry and your neurochemistry
is designed to no matter how big your
meal was last time to get you back out
hunting again it's just how it works all
desire is like that it's cyclical
it'll feel awesome for a minute for a
day for a week maybe a month
but let me tell you you're going to want
to get back out there you're going to
want to hunt you're going to want to
accomplish again so don't value yourself
for that this is how people end up
making a billion dollars only to feel as
lost and empty as ever
you have a hole inside of you that can
only be filled with progress meaning and
purpose it can't be filled with
accomplishment irony of ironies
but that's the way an evolutionarily
derived mind works
you have to be pushed to go on the
journey
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over
satiety
satisfaction contentment
or anathema
to Nature to survival so of course
you're never going to be able to sit in
that
you're going to keep going again and
again and again and again
so Embrace that drive
accomplish huge things if you can
but only value yourself for the sincere
pursuit in life there are two ways to
lose way number one is to be weak to lat
grit to be emotionally unstable to be
stubborn that's where a lot of people
fall on their face they have these fun
ideas in their head and they're
constantly looking for things to affirm
that instead of doing what they need to
do which is constantly looking for ways
that you're wrong and once you start
seeking out ways you're wrong because
you're like I've gotten this far in life
being wrong what happens if I stop being
stubborn I start looking for ways that I
can learn more that I can get rid of old
ideas that aren't working for me and
really move forward and the thing that I
think is probably the most foundational
they have a fixed mindset now what is a
fixed mindset it means that you believe
your talent and intelligence are in Born
traits you're born with it and that's it
and life is about making the best of
that and we're going to debunk the sh
out of that the second way that things
can go wrong is they're chasing the
wrong thing I'm telling you right now
the punch line to life is not success
it's not fame it's not money it's not
accolades it is very simple it's brain
chemistry AKA fulfillment the only thing
that really matters at the end of the
day is how you feel about yourself when
you are by yourself now let's talk about
the more important part which is earning
credibility with yourself
this was one of the big breakthroughs in
my life was realizing that if I said I
was going to do something
and I wanted to give up on it I would
think about well if I position it this
way if I move this way if I kind of hide
this from that person and sweep this
under the rug over here then I can still
manage other people's beliefs about who
I am
and as long as other people think that
I'm cool I'm good I'm talented I'm smart
whatever then I'm good and what I
realized is a that only works fifty
percent of the time so 50 of the moves
that you make to try to
um manage your persona
fifty percent of the time it works the
other fifty percent of the time though
people see through it and then you begin
to earn the reputation of being a
[ __ ] artist so what I realized was
okay not only does it not work as well
externally as I think but it doesn't
matter what the outside world thinks if
I don't think positively of myself so
that became my obsession is
understanding credibility is most
important when you're talking about
self-credibility and how we earn
credibility with ourselves is by saying
I'm going to do this thing and then
doing it and then you just keep inching
that out farther and farther and farther
until you get to the point where you
show up for yourself in the most extreme
and difficult of circumstances so I'll
tell you guys a story
um at my old house I used to have this
painting of the Michael Jordan Flu Game
hanging above my fireplace and that was
so inspiring to me and I always said I
put that up there to remind find myself
of what I'm capable of and how I would
react if I were put in a championship
game situation and then lo and behold
the Flash Forward probably a year later
and I actually get the flu and I have a
double episode the next day and I
remember I had a fever I was rocked I
could barely stand up it was really
miserable and I had to do all the prep
the day before for the episodes
and I was like I actually don't know if
I'm going to be able to make it through
this like it it that's how sick I was
it's one of the sickest I've ever been
discipline now we're not doing
discipline because our parents tell us
to we're doing discipline as a test to
see if it worked to get us towards our
goal now if you have historically
struggled with putting discipline in
place in your life right now you're
going to say but Tom I can't stick to
discipline so why would this work this
time that's when we realize one
fundamental truth
this is a desire problem
masquerading as a discipline problem
once you want your goal
the way that a drowning man wants his
next breath you will find discipline
very easy to stick to and so learning to
build your desire for the goal that you
have set for yourself that becomes the
incredibly important part and the way to
dial that desire up is to do a loop and
it goes like this you're going to tell
yourself that you're very excited about
this goal
you're going to tell other people that
you're very excited about this goal and
then you're going to embody
the feeling the amplitude that you want
to feel when you think about that goal
now there's a mechanism in the human
mind where it will justify the way that
you act no matter what I won't waste
time explaining some of the studies but
they are utterly fascinating about how
even people with damaged areas of the
brain will end up making up random ass
stories because the brain aborts a a
lack of reason so the the brain will
always and forever make up some story
about why you're doing what you're doing
and so if you're responding hugely to
something oh my God I'm so excited about
doing this thing like I'm really amped
up about it and you're saying that to
yourself and you're saying it to other
people and you're saying it just like
that
then the brain goes there must really be
something here we've got this elevated
level of emotion amazing let's leverage
that and the brain doesn't say let's
leverage that but the brain will say
okay we've got this elevated level
you're going to leverage the fact that
the brain says that to repeat it to
reinforce and over time you actually
just will feel that heightened level of
emotion it's the way the brain works
what you repeat you become neurons that
fire together wire together things that
you do frequently including embodying
that amplitude of emotion right Lisa
Feldman Barrett's book how emotions are
made talks about how it starts with the
body and then the brain applies meaning
to it so if you're getting amped up
you're excited the body is saying to the
brain yo like we're amped we're excited
we're doing these things and the Brain
goes oh amazing it must be because this
really matters and once you get the
brain saying hey we're this excited
because it matters you're firing those
neurons together
the excitement around this thing so the
excitement and the pursuit of that thing
begin to mesh and now we just over time
have a an actual desire to pull this off
once we have the actual desire to pull
this off then all of a sudden putting
that discipline in place becomes very
easy
and that's the name of the game
you want to make it such that you want
it badly enough that the discipline
becomes easy to stick to because it's
going to move you towards that thing
that you really want
but you've got to learn
you've got to learn to want that thing
now
I'll give my typical disclaimer
this trick works incredibly well now it
only works on things you actually have a
legitimate interest in you couldn't
um get yourself excited about something
that you truly just find stupid but
something where you actually do get a
natural response you actually are
naturally into that thing all we're
doing is dialing it up right so if it's
already a dial tone there's nothing you
can do to change the amplitude but if
the amplitude is already there and you
get this reaction we can really
exaggerate that reaction and build that
desire to get where we're going now
since that is the case you need to be
very careful what you apply this to
because you can end up really wanting
some stupid [ __ ] I know from experience
I dialed the dial on my desire for money
I cranked that to a 20. and then spent
eight and a half years pursuing money
only to come out completely miserable so
don't waste your time dialing that up on
something that isn't exciting and
honorable meaning again honorable it
elevates you and other people not just
you
all right
be careful what you decide to want but
know that it's very powerful I want to
talk about Jocko willing's idea of no
matter what life throws at you the
reaction is good I lost my job good my
woman left me for no reason good people
took money from me good all of it good
once you flip that switch in your mind
like even if that gave me the chills
just thinking how powerful
the reaction to the world's most
negative news to say good yeah good now
you have to come up with a reason why
it's good and the reason that it's good
is because you know
that the only way to think about failure
quote unquote failure is like AI
artificial intelligence okay and a i
it's not called failure it's called a
sample okay you try something so if
you've ever seen the video of AI
learning to play the video game
breakthrough the old Atari game it is
hilarious you see this paddle squiggling
around like crazy the obviously the AI
has no idea what it's supposed to do so
all it's programmed to do is get a high
score but it doesn't know what gives it
a score it doesn't know am I supposed to
move the paddle am I supposed to hit the
ball is the ball supposed to you know
break through the blocks at the top and
so it just like does these random ass
movements and then finally it'll hit the
ball and then finally the ball breaks a
break and then finally it finds the most
efficient path to break all of it now
let me tell you in my 20s I don't know
about you but in my 20s I was a mess in
my early 20s I was so lost
frustrated
afraid insecure
overwhelmed
paralyzed I mean it was it was a dark
period in my life
that's the nature of your 20s now in my
20s as old as this is going to make me
sound in my 20s the internet barely
existed so we certainly didn't have
YouTube there wasn't people putting out
content that would allow me to
recontextualize my world the fact that
you already know the quote that success
is going from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm you
were so much farther ahead than where I
was
now I'm going to use an analogy of love
if I may
one of the things I find most
interesting about love is that
in love
you are opening yourself up to being far
more easily hurt
when you are in love it's a very
vulnerable state you have opened
yourself to somebody you've given
yourself over in a way to that person
and now you are far more easily hurt
they know your insecurities they could
weaponize them against you
and when heartbreak comes along
it's very tempting to Turtle up
and to protect yourself
but then you're closed off from the
things that make love valuable in the
first place the very thing that makes
love worthwhile is being able to be open
like that to somebody to be vulnerable
to somebody and the thing that makes
love so extraordinary
is that even when you get hurt
the people that can open themselves up
again and approach somebody
without the baggage of previous
relationships are the ones that end up
finding that beautiful relationship that
ends up being worth the vulnerability
and worth the sacrifice and speaking
from experience ends up being the single
greatest thing in your life
now if you learned nothing from the
Heartbreak I understand why it's scary
to go into the next thing
but the idea here the very way that we
bounce back from failure is by looking
exclusively at what we can do
differently
and when you look exclusively I'm not
saying other people didn't do something
that maybe it's
maybe any rational person would say it's
all their fault maybe the list of things
you gave us is literally you were just
the world's unluckiest human being
but the reason that we're going to say
good the reason that we're going to look
at this like Ai and samples the reason
we're going to remind ourselves that
success is going from failure to failure
to failure without a loss of enthusiasm
the reason that we're going to think of
that love analogy and be willing to open
ourselves back up
is because we're going to figure out
what we could have done differently
we're going to see what can I improve in
my skill set what did this catastrophe
reveal about my strategy and whenever a
strategy yields a result different than
the desired result then you know the
strategy is by definition wrong
and I want you to own that doesn't mean
you're a bad person okay but it does
mean that your strategy wasn't working
go back to AI right it's wiggling around
it finally realizes oh I need to hit the
ball Okay cool so now I'm going to track
the movement of the ball and I'm going
to adjust my paddle to be there okay
cool I got it oh I actually see that
hitting it on the sides is far more
advantageous than hitting it in the
middle because once I clear a path on
the side then the ball can bounce around
on the top and Destroy bricks far faster
than any other strategy okay amazing but
you had to First have the reaction that
that failure was good good because it
revealed the flaw in my strategy and
because I'm playing the long-term game
I'm going to open myself back up again
I'm going to allow myself to be
vulnerable again I'm going to
let the wound hurt as much as it needs
to for me to learn the lesson no more
not going to beat myself up over it I'm
not going to end up in a death spiral of
Shame
but I am going to recognize that I could
do something different the next time and
get a different result
that to run the same strategy and expect
the result to change is as Einstein said
the definition of insanity
so that's what you have to do here you
have to recognize that this thing that
you consider the worst thing that ever
happened to you with a change of framing
is actually the best thing that ever
happened to you and if you change the
question that you ask about this
and say how did this help me what did I
learn from this or what could I learn
from this and how can this improve my
strategy moving forward then all of a
sudden the frame of reference changes
the emotion the way you feel about it
the dark energy that's around it begins
to change because you're stoked right
this is good all right I'm gonna learn
something from this and it's going to be
XYZ and maybe you only get incrementally
better and you try again and maybe you
fail again and you get incrementally
better and all of a sudden if your life
is anything like mine your 20s were
getting kicked in the face over and over
and over but getting a little bit better
at blocking a little bit better at
avoiding and then finally in your 30s
you begin to find your footing and then
you turn into beast mode late 30s early
40s and now
you feel like you can really
move the world
it's exactly what it feels like when you
understand how your own mind works how
the minds of others work and just sort
of the nature of the world
it's really incredible but the only way
to get there is to flounder around to
make horrendous mistakes and say good if
grit is as important as we say it is
sustained interest over time that's
really what grit is
and a lot of people talk about in fact
the title of my speech is supposed to be
about how you develop a passion which we
will talk about in a little bit but this
is going to be one of those things when
you have passion one of the things that
comes out of that is you've got the
ability to sustain your interest over
time do the hard things
do the hard things I can't emphasize
that one enough
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
just to find the mental tactics that
you're going to need to deal with the
hard things it's getting those tactics
who knows the Stanford marshmallow test
all right for those of you that don't
this is one of the most breathtaking
examples of The Human Condition in the
Stanford marshmallow test they bring in
another five or six years old they bring
them in and the person in the white lab
coat says here's a marshmallow I'm gonna
go out of the room for a minute I'll be
back in just a few minutes if you wait
till I come back I'll give you a second
marshmallow so essentially double your
money
not bad now what the kid doesn't know is
the researcher is never coming back and
all they want to know is how long will
you wait before you eat the marshmallow
some kids have literally gobbled it up
before they even get to the door
other kids are like singing to
themselves putting their head down
getting up dancing around the room some
of them bite like the underside and try
to put it back so you can't see
and here's what's scary
they followed those kids for 25 years
and based solely on the length of time
they were able to wait before they ate
the marshmallow predicted their level of
success in school
predicted their level of success in the
job market the people who waited the
longest got into the best schools got
the best grades went on to have the
highest paying jobs
just your ability to delay gratification
your ability to find tactics that work
to get your mind off something
there's no greater control than control
over oneself
anybody here ever done a three-day water
only fast not intermittent fasting
three days
do it you will learn something about
yourself and it will be profound and
what you're going to learn is that your
body is manipulative
and I did a three-day fast just a couple
weeks ago
and I had the flu right before so there
were cough drops laying around
and every time I walk by those cough
drops
my brain was like eat one
and I was like like
you know I'm fasting
and I literally couldn't believe like
how consistently every time I walk by
those damn cough drops that my body like
gave me this really intense impulse
and that's when I realized like the
notion that there are multiple voices in
your head by the way is very very real
and I will give you one quick example
who knows what the corpus callosum is
all right the corpus callosum is the
thick bit of tissue that connects the
left and right hemisphere of your brain
If you sever that you will get people
that have literal multiple personalities
one in the right one on the left some of
the most intriguing stuff is one of them
will be devoutly religious and the other
will be devoutly atheist in the same
brain and you can talk to them
differently
absolutely crazy
but the multiple voices notion is real
there are multiple
factions if you will pieces that your
brain is broken up into and by the way
you have the equivalent of a cat's brain
in neurons just in your digestive tract
so the whole notion of gut instinct
think of all the cool cats can do
and you've got that
in your digestive tract neurons
it's literally the same material that
your brain is made out of is in your
digestive tract it's utterly fascinating
so we have all these competing things
that we want
but inside if you think of that
OverWatch that one person that's you
that's meant to say I have goals and I'm
going to act in accordance with my goals
I'm never going to sell out what I want
most for what I want right now I wanted
a cough drop right now but I wanted to
get on the other side of the three-day
fast and say I did it and I wanted that
more
and in learning what your tools and
tactics are so for me I welcome hunger
like an old friend and I literally
people must think I'm schizophrenic
because you'll walk into the room and
I'll literally be like pinching and
poking at my fat going hunger thank you
I'm so glad you made it back it is so
good to see you I'm glad you're here I
know that you're oxidizing my fat and
I'm very grateful for that so thank you
and in doing that I reframe it not as
something that is unwanted or painful
but it's something that is doing exactly
what I want it to do
and learning those mental tactics that's
the game learning those mental tactics
that's the game that's how you're going
to get good at whatever it is you want
to do if you want to start a business
learning how to deal with your employees
is absolutely critical but let me tell
you right now if you lash out
emotionally your employees will lose
respect for you
but it's just like the cough drop moment
now if somebody had seen me walk by the
cough drop they wouldn't know that I had
it literally had to stop myself from
lunging at a cough drop
they didn't know that because I have
control of myself
I've practiced things like that I do
three day fast I do what I call Bright
lines
so I have a bright line
during the week I don't eat my second
meal before 11 30. under any
circumstance
my wife one time brought my food 30
minutes early I Was preparing for an
episode it was so sweet of her
but I don't eat before 11 30 under any
circumstance so the food literally sat
on my lap smelling so good and I was so
hungry and I said hunger thank you so
much for showing up because you're
giving me the opportunity to prove to
myself what a badass I am because I'm
gonna smell how delicious you are
knowing my stomach is grumbling and
tying itself in knots because I want to
eat so badly and I'm not going to
and in those moments you earn
credibility with yourself
I hate working out
absolutely despise it it's why I do it
first thing in the morning
and the reason I hate it the weights are
heavy
and your muscles start burning when you
get into the supposed good reps
so that just seems backwards
so it is not in any way shape or form
fun for me
but I earn credibility with myself
because it is something that I don't
like
I earn credibility with myself showing
up every day and it also reminds me how
much I can transform my body it's very
easy for me to show you my before and
after picture I used to be 60 pounds
heavier it's very easy for me to show
you when I was heavy and then show you
six-pack abs you get it
but what you don't see is the body's
just a reflection of the Mind
what really happened
was I changed my mind and I had garnered
skills I had garnered tactics the things
that allowed me to not eat the coffee
drop were the things that allowed me to
not eat the things that I wanted to not
have a bowl of ice cream to not indulge
in things that are wonderfully delicious
but instead ask myself what are my goals
and then back in with my behaviors
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the recent one-on-one
interview I did with Tom bill you check
it out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I was worth two
million dollars on paper and I'd never
been more unhappy in my life